تستمر الاحتجاجات التي يقوم بها صرب شمالي
كوسوفو مطالبه بسحب قوات الشرطه من امام
المباني العامه وتعلن المظاهرات التي
اندلعت في مناطق تسكنها اغلبيه صربيه
رفضها تعيين عمد فازوا في انتخابات
البلديه قطعها الصرب بامر من سلطات في
صربيا المجاوره توتر دعت واشنطن والعواصم
الغربيه لوقفه بينما تمسكت الحكومه
باجراءاتها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كان ذاك خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي
حيثيات وخلفيات النزاع الدائر في شمال
كوسوفو وما هي الاسباب التي ادت الى
اندلاع اشتباكات بين الصرب كوسوفو وقوات
الامن
وكيف تتاثر كوسوفو ومنطقه البلقان عموما
بالاستقطابات والصراعات الدوليه القائمه
ومن هي القوه الفاعله والمؤثره في المشهد
وكيف نقرا وخريطه المواقف الامريكيه
والروسيه والاوروبيه حيل النزاع في تلك
المنطقه
وما هي فرص احتواء الازمه والحلول دون
تفجر الصراع بين صربيا وكوسوفو وما يحمل
من تداعيات على منطقه البلقان وعلى
المشهدين الاقليمي والدولي
[موسيقى]
تتالت الدعوه الخارجيه من اجل اتخاذ
اجراءات فوريه تنهي التوتر المتصاعد
بينهما بدا ان تمسك الصرب بموقفهم
والحكومه الكوسفيه باجراءاتها يشير الى ان
المشكله تعود الى جذور عميقه تجلت في
الخلاف الذي شاب الانتخابات البلديه
الاخيره وما افرزته من نتائج في ظل مقاطعه
صربيه بتشجيع من صربيا المجاوره
التوتر شمل كوسوفو تصاعد نهايه يوليو تموز
الماضي بعد اصدار السلطات قانونا يلزم
السكان بالحصول على بطاقه هويه من اصدار
البلد
واستبدال لوحات السيارات القادمه من صربيا
بلوحات من اصدار
وفي وقت علق فيه رئيس وزراء كوسوفو
البينكورتي على موجه الاحتجاجات الصربيه
بالقول ان السلطه في كوسوفو يمكن الحصول
عليها بالانتخابات وليس بالعنف اكد الرئيس
صربي الكسندر فودشيتش في المقابل ان
انسحاب رؤساء البلديات الجدد في شمال
كوسوفو هو الخطوه الاهم لوقف التوتر خطوه
لم تتخذ بعد وسط تحذيرات من وزاره
الداخليه في كوسوفو من النفخ في نيران
التصعيد وصفه دعوه المنتشره على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي للمواطنين من القوميه
الالبانيه للتظاهر في بلده متروفيتسال
الجنوبيه الشماليه البلاد بالمشبوهه
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من لندن
هذا العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه ويسترن
والباحث في شؤون البلقان من مدينه فيرونا
الايطاليه جورجيو فروشون الباحثون في شؤون
البلقان في المعهد الايطالي للدراسات
السياسيه والدوليه سابدا معك سيد ايضا من
لندن للسؤال اولا عن خلفيات هذا الصراع
بطبيعه الحال يعني الجميع يدرك ويجمع على
ان المساله لا تتعلق فقط بمجرد
عمد جدد تم انتخابهم بمقاطعه من الصرب
ولكن المساله هي اعمق من ذلك ما الذي دفع
الخلاف الى السطح هذه المره
ان سبب اعمال العنف هو النساء الخلافه
الطويل المدى بين صربيا وكوزفوا تعتبر جزء
من اراضيها واما كوزو فقد اعلنت استقلالها
في 2008 وهذا الاعلان اعترفت به معظم دول
العالم معظم اعضاء اتحاد الاوروبي ولكن
صربيا استمرت في رفضه رفض الاعتراف
باستقلال الكوسوفو والاكسوا من ذلك بل
حاولت منذ عام 2008 ان تتدخل بشكل مستمر
بشؤون الداخليه لكوسوفو
واستخدمت صربه كوزوفو كوسيله
لاخلاله باستقرار البلاد داخل كوسوفو
وبالتالي هذا مشروع وخطه صربيا لاستعاده
كوسوفو
وفيه وهذا طبعا حتى سيؤدي الكثير من
الاضطرابات في كوسوفو
على حكومه كوسوفو
غير
وتستسلم ولا تستطيع ان تدير الشؤون البلاد
لذلك فهم يقومون ما يقومون في هذه البلديه
وبالتالي هذا الموضوع قديم وهذه ليست اول
مره يقومون باثار التوترات ومع الاسف هذه
من غير محتمل تكون هذه اخر مره يقومون
بذلك
اذا اردنا ان
نتحدث عن البيئه المحيطه حاليا البيئه
السياسيه والامنيه عموما في اوروبا
المحيطه بكوسوفو وبهذا النزاع هل يمكن ان
نعزل ما يحصل حاليا داخل كوسوفو عن الوضع
الاوروبي العام وحتى عن الاصطفافات التي
انتجتها حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
العواقب السياسيه لما يحدث الان في
اوكرانيا وهنالك ايضا نتائج
سياسيه
واستقطاب على المستوى الدولي
وهذا امر واضح في البلقان حيث لدينا هناك
عده اطراف
لكن مع اعتقده
انه الامر لن يكون نفس السيناريو في
اوكرانيا نفس السيناريو بمعنى انني اعتقد
ان دور روسيا مثلا
هو غير مباشر في هذه الازمه الدور ليس
بالمباشر روسيا هي ليست لديها وجود عسكريه
او افراد من العسكريين في كوسوفا وبالتالي
ليس هنالك ايضا اي مبادره دبلوماسيه
مفتوحه فيما يتعلق بالقضيه في كونسوفو
بالتالي فان دور روسيا هو قد ربما تقوم
باستغلال عدم الاستقرار الجيو السياسي
لخدمه مصالحها بالتالي فان يجب ان لا يتم
تقليل من اهميه دور روسيا هو له تاثير
كبير لكن هذا لا يعني ان التاثير بامكانها
ان يبدا بصراع مثل الذي شاهدناه في
اوكرانيا طيب بما انك ذكرت روسيا
دكتور ايضا
وزير الخارجيه الروسيه تعمل الولايات
المتحده
بتصعيد الموقف في كتبه
ما مصلحه الولايات المتحده فيما يحصل
حاليا هناك علما ان وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي دعا الى خفض التوتر ودعا ايضا
الى انسحاب الشرطه
الشرطه كوسوفو من شمال البلاد لتهدئه
الوضع
لا اعتقد ان روسيا مصدر يمكن اعتماد عليه
حول اي معلومات تحصل فيه منطقه فروسيا مره
اخرى اقول هي تهدف الى احداث عدم
الاستقرار والفوضى والتاثير على وضع في
البلقان الولايات المتحده اتخذ موقف حول
ما حصل في كوزوفو هو موقف يدعم موقف
الصربي وهذا هو احد الاشياء المحزنه حقا
في هذه هذا الوضع الحديث
فالمعتدي في في هذا الاحداث بلا شك هم
الصرب على الارض ولكن مع الاسف انه
الولايات المتحده وفرنسا وعدم الدول
الاخرى اتخذوا موقفا بان حكومه قذف هي
المخطئه وهذا طبعا غير صحيح اطلاقا
ولا تدعمه حقائق على الارض فالصرب هم
الذين هاجموا القوات
المتحده تلعب
لعبه مزدوجه فهي تريد ان تقدم كوسوفو
وبوسنا على انهم دولتان فاشلتان
الدوله
ولا يمكننا
ان يتجاوزوا الحدود تبكين
دائما
وهو المشروع الذي فيه في الثمانينات
وادى الى اعمال العنف الدمويه في
التسعينيات
الرئيس الصربي الحالي
كان وزير الاعلام
يقوم بنفس العمل ويحاول ان ينهي ما بداه
الرئيس السابق
نعم اذا
للمتابعه في هذا المجال وللحديث ايضا عن
الخلفيات حتى منها التاريخيه القريبه قد
يكون تصاعد التوتر في كوسوفو مؤخرا ناتجا
عن عوامل جديده من قبيل الانتخابات
البلديه وما جاءت به من مواقف ونتائج كما
ذكرنا ولكن الصراع في تلك المنطقه يعود
لجذور اقدم واعمق دعونا نتابع في هذا
التقرير تلك الجذور في نظره سريعه
هذه هي كوسوفو يخبرك التاريخ عن الصراع
الدام الذي انهاه اتفاق دايتون ليفرض
سلاما هشا بين الصرب والمسلمين والكروات
سلطه بثلاثه رؤوس ومؤسسات هشه تكافح
لتعزيز الاستقرار ودرء الصراع بين مكونات
تجر وراءها ذاكره ثقيله من الاقتتال اما
الجغرافيا فتضع المنطقه على حدود اتحاد
اوروبي طرقت كوسوفو ابواب الانضمام اليه
منذ الاستقلال عن صربيا صربيا التي لم
تعترف يوما باستقلال كوسوفو متمسكه
بروايتها الخاصه عن التاريخ والديموغرافيا
ما كان الاتفاق دايتون ان يصمد لولا قوه
من الناتو تسنده وتعطي منبثق عنه وجودا
وسلطه على الارض على الارض تفاصيل ورهانات
متضاربه تصل حد رفض اصدار بطاقه هويه
ولوحات سيارات تظهر مقدارا من السياده
المحليه ناهيكم عن انتخابات بلديه قاطعها
بتحريض من بيجراد ترى واشنطن انه كان بوسع
الحكومه معالجه الموقف بطريقه مختلفه اي
اكثر مرونه بينما تبدو السلطات برشتينا
حريصه على غلق الباب امام ما قد يتهدد
كيانها لفائده اجنده خارجيه ذاك هو واقع
كوسوفو وقدرها في مواجهه جمر للقوميات لم
ينطفئ بعد تحت رماد السلام
من جديد الى ضيفنا من
الى ضيفنا جورجيو
الموجود في فيرونا الايطاليه سيد فروشون
هل يمكن ان نشاهد تصعيدا عسكريا جديدا او
حربا جديده الان انطلاقا من شمال كوسوفو
مع صربيا
اخرى في اوروبا وذلك لعده اسباب اولا
هنالك اسباب
اقتصاديه فان الطرفين ليس لديهم
الامكانيات والميزانيه العسكريه وسبب
الثاني وهو الاهم في رايي ان هذا الامر
سيكون انتحارا عسكريا لتربيه اذا ما ارادت
مهاجمه كوسوفو لانه في كوسوفا هنالك اكبر
قوه للنيتو بالتالي كما قلت سيكون انتحارا
عسكريه لها ايضا من الجانب الدبلوماسي
فان كل طرفين يلتقران الى الدعم من شركاء
ما بالتالي ليس هنالك اي شريك لاي من
الطرفين سيدعم اي مغامره عسكريه حتى روسيا
بامكانها ان ربما لن تقوم بمثل هذه الحرب
ربما قد تدعمها على المستوى اللفظي واللغه
لكن ليس ان يكون لك تدخل عسكري حسب راي ان
منع
حرب جديده هو ليس فقط امر مناسب لكلا
الطرفين لا يقتصر على هذا الامر اذا على
الطرفين عليهما ان يستفيداء من
مساله انه هنالك فكره وجود حرب جديده لكن
لن تبدا هذه الحرب بالتالي
هنالك مساله فكره الانتقام من العدو
القديم والحديث عن هذا الامر قد يكون
نافعا للطرفين لكن لن تصل الامور الى شن
والبدء مثل هذه الحرب وهذا يعني هذا خيط
رفيع يصبح سيد ايضا دكتور ادم من لندن
الان اذا اردنا ان نتحدث عن القوه الدوليه
الان خريطه الصراع في الداخل اصبحت معروفه
الاسباب التي لها علاقه
بالانتخابات التي قطعها صرب ايضا اصبحت
معروفه لكن السؤال من هو المستفيد من حاله
التصعيد هذه التي تبرز مره بعد اخرى
وتكاثرت في الاونه الاخيره اذا كان كما
يقول ضيفنا من ايطاليا كل الاطراف
الاوروبيه ترفضها بما فيها كذلك الولايات
المتحده
اتفق مع الضيف الاخر لا اعتقد صربيا ستقوم
بغزو رسميا
لكوسوفلالك ينباع ضربا من الجنون ولكن هذا
لا يعني ان لن تكونوا يفكروا باخلال
الاستقرار
مع الاسف بامكان تستخدم عصاباتها
الاجراميه الموجودون في الشمال الكوزوفو
هذه العصابه تعمل بشكل كافر بافلات من
العقاب داخل صربيا وكذلك داخل هذه
البلديات في شمال كوسوفو وان حكومه
بالاغراض قد تستخدم هذه العصابات لزياده
او للتصعيد التوترات على امل ان ذلك سيؤدي
الى اثاره قوات كوسوفو
للهجوم على الجاليه السلبيه موجوده في
كوزوفو لماذا يفعلون ذلك لماذا يستفيد من
ذلك يريد
الرئيس
صربيا هو الذي يمكنني ياتي بالاستقلال
المنطقه وان كوزوف وهي التي تخل
بالاستقرار وان الالبانيين في كوزوفو
خارجونا عن القانون لا يصلح حكم نفسهم
ديمقراطيا وايضا يخلق اسطوره بان حكومه
كوزوفو هي تقمع على الاقليات وقبل ماذا
سيكون عفوا امام ذلك سيد ايضا امام امام
ذلك ماذا اين سيكون دور قوات كييفور قوات
النيتو لحفظ السلام الموجوده هي ستعزز ب
700 عنصر كما اعلن هل ستكون متفرجه ازاء
هذا السيناريو الذي تفضلت به
امل انهم يتدخلوا وقد فعلوا ذلك في
الاوضاع القريبه ولكن مع الاسف في 2004
كان هناك
هناك اضطرابات كبيره في
كوسوفو وقوات النيتو كانت غير فعاله
اطلاقا في التعامل مع تلك الازمه على
الاقل في الايام الثلاثه والاربعه الاولى
ما اقوله املا ذلك لن يتكرر مره اخرى ولكن
السياق الكبير لابد ان يؤخذ بالنظر
لاعتبار وهو
انها ان الرئيس الصربي يريد هو الذي حقق
الهدوء في المنطقه وما على السيف الكثيرون
في الغرب يصدقون ذلك وهذه هذا غير صحيح
اطلاقا فهو ما يريد تحقيقه هو الاضطرابات
في المنطقه ويريد ان يلغي الحدود بين
كوزوفو والصربيا ويريد ان وكذلك مع
مونتولي جبل الاسود وبالتالي اذا هناك اي
سلام للطريق
لن ياتي من كوزوفو مستقله بل من عوده
الشعور القومي
الطائفي
لا ادري ان كان هذا الامر يعقد من وجهه
نظر تحليليه ان كان هذا الامر يعقد الازمه
اكثر مما
يحلها سيد جورج يوفروشون
كيف يمكن لهذه الازمه ان تحل اذا كان
الموضوع عوده الحرب خط احمر فقط مجرد
توترات اذا الى اين
تتجه هذه الازمه برايك
ان المجتمع الدولي سيتدخل ببعض
علاج الوضع كما حدث في السنه الماضيه كما
حصل في علامات السيارات لكن الاهم من ذلك
وما هنالك حاجه اليه هنالك حاجه الى وساطه
لتطبيق فوري للاتفاق الذي توصل اليه
الطرفان في شهر فبراير لانه اذا ما قام
بتطبيق الاتفاق
بتسريع عمليه دمجيهما
نحو الاتحاد وانضمامنا الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي لكوسوفو وصربيا ولمنطقه البلقان
فان هذا الامر يعني الاستقرار ومن الناحيه
الجيولاسيه سيعني انه
الابتعاد من روسيا
ومساله التعامل مع قضيه كوسوفو
ايضا شيء اخر ارغب باضافته من اجل تفادي
التوتر المحلي وانا اوافق الراي مع السيد
ايدن هنالك
لكي لا نبالغ في التشريع السياسي اللي
مساله التوتر في البلقان لانه كانت هذه
قضيه الرئيس الصربي بوجهي الذي يتمتعه
بدعم القاده الاوروبيين لعشر سنوات وايضا
وكما ذكر السيد ايضا هو لا يدعم السلام
والمصالحه لكنه يدعم الاضطرابات وهو يقوم
بذلك باختصار باختصار سيد جورج باختصار
باختصار اساسا الاتحاد الاوروبي مستعد
لضم صربيا وكوسوفو يعني
كي يكون جزءا من الاتحاد الاوروبي هل هو
مستعدون في الوقت الحاضر باختصار على
اعتبار انها يمكن ان تحل الازمه
انه اذا ما كان هنالك تطبيق للاتفاق فستتم
عمليه تسريع الانضمام لكن لم يتم تطبيق
هذا
لانه اذا لم يتم تطبيق هذا الامر لن يحدث
بالتالي هو هي شراكه بناء
ان كلا الطرفين عليهما ان يحققا شيء
بالتالي يجب على البلدان ان يكون جاهزين
للانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
من مدينه فيرونا الايطاليه البحث المختص
في شؤون البلقان شكرا جزيلا لك واشكر من
لندن الدكتور
ايدن هيه هير استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في
جامعه ويست منستر والباحث ايضا في شؤون
البلقان
انتهت حلقتنا من برنامج ما وراء الخبر
شكرا للمتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]